[Musique]
numéro sept rangées bruyamment
numéro 6 voire bruyamment
[Musique]
numéro 5 on a fait très fort sur son
clavier
ah bon numéro mais son doigt pour
tourner les pages numéro froid
[Musique]
sans micro chine est encore un peu court
numéro 2 à réfléchir à vos comme si
excusez moi c'est vous du chef du groupe
au même jeu désolé je ne vois dans ma
bulle c'était le dire j'ai surtout vu le
jour c'est ma provocation at il ajouté
donnez le moi voilà comme ça vous pouvez
enfin champion toutes catégories de
regarder un film porno en branchant
[Applaudissements]
green au talent exceptionnel et on aura
ta gueule ça tous les mercredis et tous
les jeudis à 20h50 je vous le dit demain
on aura une autre une inédite celle de
demain mais je pense que vous avez
chialer de rire encore